joining me now Riley Gaines she's a
spokeswoman with the Independent Women's
forum and former swimmer at the
University of Kentucky Riley I mean the
President also said the event was deeply
traumatic for the students but not for
you who is actually assaulted apparently
your response tonight to what you just
heard
I mean you can't even make this up
exactly like you said this is what
higher institutions are are doing
universities where children are going to
learn this is what they are teaching
them they also responded in the email
with saying you know we know how hard it
can be to hear other perspectives so
here are some counseling resources for
for you students who were so brave my
response is we must have different
definitions of peaceful because these
videos what I heard what I endured for
three hours sitting barricaded in a room
where they demanded money if I wanted to
safely make it home that is not peaceful
that's kidnapping and extortion
now Jamila Moore as I said that staffer
that sent the email out to the students
Riley following your event also said
that we value different ideas even when
they're not our own but then yesterday
you tweeted that it was this individual
Jamila Moore
blocked you on Twitter so what happened
to the exchanging views and the beauty
of the exchange and the tolerance and
the inclusivity what happened to that
you know the Dei stuff it only works if
it's in agreeance with what they're
pushing because in reality diversity is
racism and Equity it's it's segregation
these these ideas they're pushing it's
not indicative of what the messaging is
that they're using it's manipulative
it's violent this whole movement it's
vengeful it's hateful I've never seen a
movement quite like this movement
well the protection of women and girls
in sports Act of 2023
seeks to clarify can you believe we have
to clarify Title IX by classifying
athletes by biology rather than whatever
they claim to be on any given day but
this isn't apparently sitting well with
some of the most famous female athletes
like Soccer Star Megan Rapinoe WNBA star
Sue bird and others released a statement
today saying they believed and they
believe in gender equity and in sports
it's critical our deepest hope is that
transgender and intersex kids will never
have to feel the isolation exclusion and
other ring
that H.R 734 is seeking to enshrine into
law Riley
are you trying to
I guess perform othering against other
individuals I don't even know what that
means this is so idiotic Riley I know
your reaction no I'm not
and my my response to this is both Megan
rapino and Sue bird are done playing and
both of them will not procreate because
they're not attracted to men so neither
one of these women have daughters to
defend and they're done playing sports
so it doesn't matter to them
well I like to put any really really
strong Varsity you know high school you
know athlete against Megan Rapinoe
soccer player and see how she liked
playing all right Riley thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else